à chaque meeting son lot de performances
marie-amélie le fur n'est pas toujours à
l'aise sur les sautoirs blésois mais là
5 mètre 60 et alba son propre record de
bon augure pour la suite de sa saison
j'ai besoin confié que le sauteur
derrière dans lequel j'étais très
contente quand ça sort là ce soir en
présence des coachs du public d'un temps
qu'il faut mais finalement qui est idéal
et qui nous rappelle celui que l'on
connaîtra doigts doha les championnats
du monde handisport objectif annoncé de
la vendômoise actuellement en plein
travail échéances internationales pour
les uns nationale pour les autres qui
deviennent durs shun n'est plus licencié
à tour mais s'il continue à s'entraîner
en indre et loire
vainqueur du concours de javelot mais
en-deça des 70 m il est en retard dans
sa préparation
ça ne lui convient pas ça fait toujours
plaisir d'être repoussé par le public et
tout ça mais je sens que je chante sur
un jeu comme ça il ya encore beaucoup
beaucoup de marge et ça ça commence à
m'agacer c'est un peu frustrant parce
que quand il est content quand on sait
qu'on a lancé à près de 80 net il ya un
an et demi deux ans est clair qu'on n'y
arrive plus c'est assez énervant reste
quelques semaines aux athlètes pour
régler les derniers détails techniques
les championnats de france sont
programmés à villeneuve d'ascq les 11 et
12 juillet parmi les engagés le
montargois salim sdiri sans pression
particulière
en vieux briscard qu'il est maintenant
j'arrive sur mes 37 engins carrière juge
est chaud pour pas mal mais tu me suis
pété cet été ça au printemps on prépare
une grosse blessure
et puis bon bah après il suffit que je
fais que ça revienne au bon moment c'est
tant pis il faut un saut une fois une
perche 7 mètres 34 pts podium en
longueur pour salim sdiri à blois mais
il n'était pas venu pour ça il termine
sa préparation
sinon est une qui fait prête c'était là
la blésoise et midi menu est déjà
qualifié pour les championnats du monde
de marche a fait cavalier seul sur le
5000 m avec un nouveau record de france
à la clé